quickly though you can give a comment
it's okay we don't need to keep on
arguing I don't understand you don't
want to submit and you think it's
suppressing but we can be on the same
page if you can submit to me then we can
be on the same page submit to what I was
in my femininity submit to your
femininity come home to her give her
kisses sometimes like that for me do
what you think a woman needs to do and
have the baby so do you want a masculine
man or a feminine man what obviously a
masculine like obviously men men don't
know each other so if you want a
masculine man you know if you want a
masculine man then I can't submit to you